All right, so we've established that we can do
this t-test and compute these t-values and nu values
and, and p-values in the abstract mathematical sense, but
you might be wondering how do I do this
in python? Is there a simple way to do
this? Well, the answer is yes, this can be
done in the following way. First you simply import
scipy.stats. And then you call scipy.stats.ttest_ind and then supply
as arguments two lists, which are your two
sets of data, and then an optional argument,
equal_var=false. This indicates whether or not we think
the variance of our two samples is equal. This
equal_var=false argument makes this particular call of the
t-test equal to Welch's t-test. This function will
return a tuple. The first value is the
t-value for your data. And the second value is
the corresponding p-value for a two-tailed test. The values
returned by scipy.stats.ttest_ind assumes that you are performing a
two-sided t-test where we're only testing for whether the
means of our two samples are different. Say we
wanted to do a one-sided t-test, that is, we're
interested in testing whether one mean in particular is
greater than or less than the other. How might
we do this given the output that this function produces?
Write your answer in the text box below. Here's a hint. We can still use
the t value and p value that this
function returns. Don't worry. This won't be graded.